[موسيقى]
العالم باسره يتحدث عن حرب انستغرام
من تحول الاجيال الاكثر شبابا نحو المنصه
الصينيه التي تكسر كل الارقام لكن هناك
لاعب اخر في المواجهه وهو يوتيوب شورتز
[موسيقى]
العام الجديد قد يشهد منافسه مشتعله ايضا
بين تيك توك ويوتيوب شورز وهي منصه
الفيديوهات
التي تاتي من بعيد
واعلان يوتيوب سماحه لصانعي المحتوى بكذب
المال من خلال اليوتيوب شورز في العام
2023 اثاره اهتمام المبدعين الذين يعاني
كثيرا منهم بالفعل من شرح الارباح على
التيك توك
[موسيقى]
لكن مع صعوبه تحقيق دخل ثابتن ومريح على
تيك توك الا انه لا يزال اكثر تطورا واسهل
في الاستخدام والشكوى العامه لصناعه
المحتوى المخلصين يوتيوب انا ادوات الشورت
مربيتون ولا تساعد على انتاج فيديو قريب
من جوده تيك توك يوتيوب عملاق الفيديو
يخشى فقدان الرياضه
لكن هل تشعر المنصه الصينيه بالتهديد لا
يبدو ذلك
ارخص للاعلانات للسيطره على سوقها وحتى
الان يبدو ان لا شيء يمكن ان يوقف تيك توك
[موسيقى]